there's a lot to love about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it's got action
adventure and baby Groot
that's what everyone adores about the
MCU but there's one thing the sprawling
multi-billion dollar movie series hasn't
gotten quite right LGBTQ community
representation many fans have called for
Marvel to remedy this the proposed
solution simply include more LGBTQ
characters in the MCU and according to
Marvel Studios President Kevin Feige
that's exactly what the company plans to
do speaking in an interview with The
Playlist Feige revealed that Marvel
Studios will introduce at least two
LGBTQ characters in the future one will
be someone fans have never seen on the
big screen before and another will be a
character viewers are already familiar
with the executive didn't mince words or
skirt around the topic when it was
brought up when asked if a gay bi LGBTQ
out character in the MCU was in the
works
Feige responded yeah that's the answer
both ones you've seen and ones you
haven't seen though Feige didn't dish up
any additional details keeping a tight
lip on the characters identities it's
widely assumed that tessa Thompson's
thor ragnarok hero Valkyrie is the LGBTQ
character who's already graced us with
their presence
the actress previously confirmed that
Valkyries bisexual writing on Twitter
back in October of 2017 she's bi and yes
she cares very little about what men
think of her what a joy to play as god
is in danger if people are dying we need
to get back down need your help
finished bye sadly only part of that
proclamation was reflected in the final
version of the movie Valkyrie certainly
didn't care about men's opinions but the
single scene that addressed her
sexuality was cut from the film after
the devastating events of Avengers
infinity war we aren't sure whether
Valkyrie is actually alive still fans
have their fingers crossed that she's a
okay and would be out and proud in an
upcoming Marvel movie especially since
that will reflect the characters
modern-day comic book identity as for
who the brand-new LGBTQ character is and
where they may first appear the
possibilities are endless well brie
Larson's Carol Danvers have a lead
and Captain Marvel or could spider-man
far from home introduce an LGBTQ team
vigilante like America Chavez to banter
by Spidey side your guess is as good as
ours but when it comes down to it we're
just excited that Marvel is taking any
sort of initiative to make its movie
universe more inclusive about time
[Music]